Hey, Senpai! Wait for me!
Sorry to bother you, but if you're not too busy, I was wondering if you'd be open to
studying for our finals together tonight. I heard you complaining with your friends
earlier about how scared you might fail. Maybe studying together might help you feel better about it?
Hmm? Senpai, are you unsure?
What if I straighten the teal a little?
We don't have to only study. We could do more if you want. We could have lots of fun together, don't you think?
Ah, I'm happy to hear that. I expected to see you at 7 today then. Make sure you wear something cute.
I know I will. See you later then!
Ah, Senpai, you made it! I'm so happy to see you. Do you like my skirt? I wore it just for you.
I saw you looking at some girls today wearing short skirts like this,
so I assume you like them. It's cute, isn't it?
You're so sweet. I usually wouldn't wear skirts while I'm lounging around the house,
but if it's for you, then I don't mind it. I would do a lot more for you.
If you just said the word.
Uh, I'm sorry. That was weird. Why don't you come in? I left you waiting long enough.
Right over here, I set up a little study station at the coffee table with snacks too, of course.
Really? That's your favorite brand of chips? What a coincidence. It's my favorite too.
I didn't know we had so much in common. Have a seat.
Ah, no, sorry. The other hand, this drink is yours. Sorry, I'm just really picky about,
um, how much ice is in my drink? Yeah, sorry.
So, do you have any specific classes you're struggling with the most?
I know for me, I'm really struggling in English class. That teacher's so damn picky about her
metaphors and sonnets or whatever. How's her name again? Ms. Simone? She's such a press.
You like her? Why? You think she's pretty? Of course you do.
Don't you think, um, your drink is getting warm? Maybe you should drink it while it's cold?
You don't care?
Right, yeah, sorry. There's no reason to care. It's just a me thing, I guess. I'm just picky like that.
We can continue studying, or you could tell me what it is about Ms. Simone that you like exactly.
I just want to know. Don't you talk about it with your bros all the time? Why not tell me?
I'm no different than them. Am I?
Right, yeah, I'm not. Just tell me what you like about her. Is it her boobs? They're pretty big,
right? Is that what you like? I bet she wears a push-up bra. Or maybe they're even fake.
Or do you like her nails? She always has them done so nicely. I wish I had time to do them like that.
I'm always so busy trying to keep up with you. I mean, trying to keep up with your grades. Yeah,
you're a lot smarter than me. I want to have good grades like you. So I spend a lot of time studying.
Yeah, that's why I invited you here today. Maybe some of your intelligence can rub off on me a little.
Anyway, why won't you just tell me? I want to know what makes her so special.
What makes every other girl so much better than me?
Hmm? Sampai? You look a little nervous and sweaty. Perhaps all that sweating has left you thirsty?
Why don't you just have a sip of your drink? I made it especially for you.
Come on. Just one sip. Do it.
Oh, these? I'm just using them to cut a page of my notebook out.
No need to worry about it. I would never use these scissors on you.
Unless, of course, you were to disrespect me badly enough,
to the point where I felt like I needed to use them.
For example, not drinking the juice I worked so hard to make for you.
I'd squeeze those oranges with my bare hands, you know?
That's right. What a good boy. That's right. Drink up.
Drink all of it. I don't want to see a single drop left in that cup once you're done.
Good job. Thank you for that. I was getting worried for a second that you didn't actually
want to be here, and you only said yes to studying with me so you didn't hurt my feelings.
But it seems you actually do care about me. I'm glad. I care about you a lot, too, you know?
More than I let on. Why don't we start actually studying?
Let's start with English. Then we can move on to whatever subject you need help with.
Here's a question I would have trouble answering.
How does Hamlet's view of Rosencrantz and Guildenstern change?
I don't remember anything from Hamlet. Do you remember Senpai?
Senpai? Senpai? Can you hear me? I asked you a question, silly. Answer me.
Hey.
Finally. I thought you would never drink it. This whole thing would have been for nothing.
It took me a lot of courage to flirt with you in public like that,
but I didn't know any other way to lure you here. You were never receptive to my more wholesome
approaches, so I had to take things a step further. I was blushing so hard after I flirted
with you in front of the whole class today, Senpai. But it was all worth it,
because now I have you to myself, and I don't have to worry about anyone else taking you away from
me anymore. Let me closer. Since you're incapacitated, I can play with you all I want.
And you can do nothing about it.
You smell so sweet. Is this new shampoo? Smells different from the usual ones.
Hang out. Keeps still and quiet for me. My walls are thin, and I don't want the neighbors in
shooting on our special alone dime. Plus, you won't need to be awake much longer now.
Let's spend these final moments of peace together.
No silly. You're not gonna die. I'm just putting you to sleep for a little bit,
that's all, sweetie. I obviously need to train you into being the perfect boy for me.
We should start with those wandering eyes, don't you think?
I can't have you thinking it's acceptable to look or talk about other girls.
Sit still, alright? It will be over before you know it.